hello
and welcome back to our second
hour of tonight i am a little excited to
show you this baby magnus edition
i had a little fun coming up with the
name i don't think we actually
landed on anyone that i
wanted to oops kind of wanted to call it
like
maybe magnus on the time machine or this
week
12 years ago actually 13 years ago oh my
god
yeah they're a lot of fun um
so we kind of oh never mind we did never
mind we did land on time machine baby
magnus yes
great that should be fun so
um let me uh one of the games
like there were there's so many great
games that magnus has
played in the tata still uh
or in the vacancy um but i think one of
like
i'm having a trouble deciding between
the one that he played against madyara
or uh the one that he
played against um
van value one of those two are
definitely
more exciting but let's start with
mehmed you're one and hopefully we can
work our way and i'll try my best to
speak a little faster than i would
usually do so
we can definitely try and fit in both
of them
all right um
so let's go let's go from
me to baby magnus um
so so far like it's a normal opening i
don't really
anticipate anything happening with this
let me also before we get too deep let
me give you a
mini background on why i am
talking about this tournament one of the
reasons that this tournament is so cool
is
because magnus had this very interesting
five wins that he really was proud of
and well as chess fans so are we
and there was another very interesting
idea
um in his in this tournament he shared
the first place
with and he was really a baby these
games are from 2008
so 2008 what uh what was i doing
2008 i had a rating of i think 1700
2008 is when i played the world u
championship
under 10 in vietnam
i was that baby and you can imagine how
baby magnus was
so yeah um so that's why we have our
baby magnus title
for now and i think this was a very
interesting game as well as tournaments
but all right let's just go ahead and
continue our um breeze through
the mammoth drf game because i really do
want to get to the van belly game
i don't i i don't exactly play this line
as
white but i am familiar with it enough
to know that i think mehmed yarf was
probably not taking magnus seriously as
as as seriously as he should have there
we go that's better wording
which is something that happens a lot
when a kid enters
the 2700 club which is actually
another reason that i'm showing you this
because i've heard
a lot of um questions and comments
on rizza fiera's jaw it's kind of funny
because my dad's name is ellie rizza
so it gets a little confusing up here um
but yeah so
fee restaurant is like baby magnus
and when like 13 years ago when magnus
had a rating of 27
33 it is similar to ali rizzo having
that rating
today and uh again in a week or so oh
sorry actually tomorrow
my bad tomorrow uh the tata still
tournament
is uh happening again and alireza is
playing in it and i think it's kind of
cool like to put these parallels
together
anyways um so just like a little
non-chess information for you chess
lovers
yeah pt i do think that um
is something that happens especially
when uh more experienced players
play the younger kid they might just
think that
he's not as experienced and they're
they're right a lot of the times they
can actually get away with
underestimating him but most of the time
it's also gets a little tricky as we're
seeing in this game
so quick question
uh for those of you who know the theory
feel free to
throw hints in the chat but for those of
you who don't play this
like me bishop takes up street what do
we think about that do you think this is
a good idea to come all the way with the
special
and take the on f3
what's up chess king
oh thank you camilo all right so i think
that
uh you guys are somewhat uh warm like
alright with this idea but
if you don't know the opening you would
probably not play this bishop g4 bishop
f3 which is very understandable
um yes if you can keep the e4 palmer it
isn't yeah okay
so i i understand this move because
your bishop it's going to have a hard
time yes you can definitely try to play
like an e6
knight e7 uh then try to like castle or
if needed
e5 but your bishop is kind of
um on the way and so if you could get
rid of it
it's not the worst idea but then again
if i looked at this position and if i
did
not know the objective theory i don't
think i would play bishop g4
bishop g4 makes sense on the sense of
all right knight d4 also may be coming
up
i'm not going to do long castle so
that's not any it doesn't really have
anything to do with that
so take take now knight f6
normal development uh in the game white
simply play d3
um there were other ideas such as knight
d5 that's worth mentioning
but d3 is simple sweet nothing wrong
with that
castle queen and now
again knight d5 is a possibility because
if you were to take it now um
let's say something like knight d4
whoops forking here
queen has to go back uh black gets this
chance to start
march on the clean side and i'm assuming
this is
not a very comfortable idea for
mamedyarov to allow
magnus to march with his queenside pawns
and this bishop also becomes a baby
monster well actually
a full-grown monster so i i would
i would generally understand why
this idea of knight d5 might not be so
pleasant
you don't want to help your opponent to
open their bishop right
so however this knight d4 is coming up
so what do you think white should do
here
this is 2008 that's why
it's a time machine and that's why it's
baby magnus
i think after after magnus won the world
title
with him the world champion or even a
year before that after 2012 magnus was
not a baby
he was a mini king let's go with that
friends
oh that just feels weird
so i agree there are some ideas that
maybe you should push this pawn
definitely because you have to the shop
opening at the center
is something that we've been taught from
when we start your learning chess
um well tata still is opening uh
starting i believe from tomorrow so we
should have a lot of fun with that
i am going to play in uh
there is like a small tournament that's
being organized by kasparov foundation
in like two three weeks i will be
playing that
i have a mock exam in less than two
weeks to
let me know how horrifyingly
it's going to hurt the mcat score
i have a mock exam from my school they
were very sweet and nice to organize
that
but i am slightly terrified by it
uh no we are looking at this week
just back into 2008 when
magnus uh then yes we're looking at two
games of magnus
all right so i see some ideas maybe
knight e2 is not a bad idea
but after knight e2 again knight d7
could be played
and or something like rook c8 or also
this knight when it forfeits this ideas
of b5 also kind of
gets a little interesting
how many hours is the mcat well mcat
is eight hours uh all together
the studying for it is something like
800 hours
all right so um
white played queen d1 i'm assuming queen
d1
is to push for f4 immediately and to
also stop the nonsense stuff with knight
d4
but honestly in the game if my opponents
played queen d1 i would internally be
just a little bit happy because i didn't
even have to attack you and you backed
out already
so just psychologically just a little
bit
anyways after queen d1 knight d7 was
played
now after f4 black to move what do you
think we should do
i'll hear you guys maybe a little less
than a minute
ha mcat i wish mcat was just a tall cat
that would make my life much easier i
just give it some tuna and be done
ah my windows are open
okay
okay
my hat is beginning to sink i'm assuming
the stray cat's his back
anyways um
so i see a lot of ideas about e5 bishop
d4s
moving the miter around a little um but
i don't see
anybody saying their rights move
even f5 is interesting but the problem
is if you play something like
f5 he's just going to play knight d5 or
he's just going to take it over here
when you take back now this bishop is
open and that's the bishop that you
don't have so something like
rookie won so
i apologize oh
so something like rookie one so this
stops your e6 ideas maybe you want to
throw in this b a bishop d5 idea
so it's not as easy as i would like it
to be
so i don't really want to play this f5
at the moment
magnus point c4
a little surprising uh for me too since
i do not play this opening
but i get it because after take most of
black's game is going to be in the king
side
sorry in the queen side while white is
marching on the king side
that was a mouthful to say uh so now
this is a new target for me to go after
now knight a5
if you play something like knight d5
boom i eat your pawn
if you don't uh if you play something
like queen d3 again or drook c8
and my ideas with taking over here
still are very valid so 10 knight d5
take take c3 to stop this ideas on b2
now black to move what do you think we
should do
i'm not very big on starbucks
merchandise but this cup
this golden cup really has gotten me
i initially bought it to give it to my
mom but i haven't really seen her since
last year
so well last year i mean thanksgiving
2019
so i kept this for myself
hello hishi we might have the cat
joining us momentarily
oh such a good boy he's right here i
don't know if you guys see him oh oh
he might be going for the microphone
please don't go for the microphone
oops good boy at least didn't
put fur next to the microphone all right
um i like the ideas of trying to
um kick this night out but i don't think
now is the right time at least not with
the pawn so
pawn e6 is a little too uh
stretching it because then knight just
goes to e3 and if f5's
f6 it just creates more weakness so it's
not a good idea to give your opponent
that
choice um
how about something like a5 i kind of
like this idea of f5 but
i agree that this knight gotta go and i
agree that
this knight is not very useful at the
moment so let's just go and try to
poke those knights away
the way if my camera starts shaking is
most likely because
the cat is trying to make it jump from
the table
to the oh no no no no no
getting next to the microphone pc i'm
going to remove this microphone gently
so there will be no cat on it at least
at the moment the last thing i need is a
def bench simon
all right
okay so um
now i like this idea of knight b6
thank you for trying my stuff on from
the floor pc one more
we'll give you gold star
and so um after knight b6
it's very interesting because you
you shouldn't take it because then i
would take it with the queen and
also your b2 is weak but that's not the
only reason
the thing with queen takes b6 is that
it's just activation
piece activation and piece activation is
very very valuable
as i have also been talking about that
in my camps
well the digital classrooms they used to
be called camps and now they're
having a little fancier name i'm not
complaining i like fancy names
so queen takes b6 attacks your king now
if you play something
like recapture to defend over here as
well just rook c8
peace activity peace activity peace
activity
and next i could even try to play
something like a5s
anyways um
let's go back so not take let's say
queen e2
now if you were to take it over here i
could simply take here attack your
knight
now checks don't work as well because
no rook f2 is needed to defend v2
and um this would still be a little
better for white because the center is
somewhat
open there's some weak mods to go after
and so
rook c8 is best thank you exquisite
now after rook c8 white whoa
that was a good jump white played king
h2
um very gently kinkage too still trying
to
save the king put it in a safe spot now
question
is it time to kick this knight away
uh
f5 to undermine maybe
i like the ideas with a5 i think a5 is
another great idea but e6 seems to be
the best one
um the idea is that if you were to
simply
take over here now taking with queen
again
gave me give gives me a lot of space and
if you were to play something like
f5 i could take it to the e pawn and
just play rook e8
uh that should be alright enough
um yes this knight is very strong i
agree if queens goes to g4
um
and then i have
rook c7
defending my stuff
i like this position it's very chill
it's very
comfortable all right um
now what about knight going to b4 when
we attack it
should we chase it with a5 or should we
just kind of let it be
um i'm a little skeptical on a5 because
knight going to d3
the point is that the knight on b4 here
isn't really doing much
so if you were to actually kick it away
it would kind of help it
now the knight is kind of defending the
position a little it's like
right back there so it's good to look
for e5s and f5 so i think python d3
actually helps white
so i don't want to help my opponent so
how about knight a4
going after this b2 pawn trying to put
more pressure on it
as much as i can now if you were to play
nice d3 which
is the best move then you could try to
play something along the lines of maybe
b5
or maybe like a5 trying to still push
for b5
or something like queen e7 then next b5
i think that would be another good idea
in the game mama dior simply played f5
now should we take this or not if not
what do you think we should do
okay so i see some nice ideas coming up
but b3 doesn't work because of this
knight takes c3 idea
um so
i don't really see too many takes or not
but the problem
is that if you were to take it over here
that only helps white because now you
have a weak pawn
you open this bishop you open that
bishop
it doesn't really help you much
so what do you think we should do
after this f5 let's say no to take
and what else should there be so if you
don't want to take
so i'm looking at your ideas and i see
the ideas with e5
i see d5 i see rookie eight i'm a little
um i'm a little surprised that nobody
wants to do
tactics do you do you guys think this
works because if take
you would take that if take you would
take over here and then take that as
well
so what do you guys think about this
position is this worth it
to be fair it's very interesting but
the problem isn't that line the problem
is right over here after
he could first of all take over here
second of all
even in this position again taking here
this
intermediate move is the problem for us
as black because if we take back now
uh there could be this check take
and then rick goes to f1 so there is no
more
attack in this file so that's the
problem
and um if you don't take it back
if you run with your knight that's
another possibility it still
holds you a good fight but it kind of
it's not the ideal so you could just
take
and well if you take now there's going
to be
um i just want this queen to get to d5
so maybe queen d1
if you take it over here i'll give you
this check
this king feels too weak just compared
to disking i don't even want to make
that comparison
uh white has a better position
it's not winning but it's definitely a
small advantage
so let's go back back back
to be fair the best move here is rookie
it's a good job on those of you who were
thinking about it
after ricky aids again if you consider
taking on b2 that is good too good job
uh but maybe a little bit easier to just
play chill rookie eight take take
and now you actually want to do the
stress because there's no more rook
takes f8 you know that's your
face f1 that we just looked at so in the
game knight goes to d3
defending over here knight c4 oops sorry
knight c5 is a great idea to keep
attacking and chasing this knight
if take we take with rook that's another
idea
uh most to be fair a lot of chess is
just about peace activity so as long as
you are activating your pieces and
not allowing your opponent to activate
his pieces
that's already a very great idea
so what about this
let's say after knight d3
knight c5 i like it but
this knight is not the only piece that
needs to be activated
so we can simply do queen b6 activate
the screen to the best diagonal
bring more stuff on b2
and kind of just wait to see what your
opponent wants to do
in the game mamadiarov played h4 now
black to move what do you think we
should do
i'm gonna give you a little hint i will
be very
pleased if anybody understands my hands
for
those of you who have been watching my
lectures quite
often if you remember the game i had
with irena crush in 2018
the game that i was super winning but i
lost this is
this move is a move that i did in that
game and like the same similar-ish idea
again if you figure it if you figure it
out i'm very impressed and if you
remember that game i'm super duper
impressed
but um
you could just think about the position
too that's the best option
whoa
what i recommend in opening and
attacking as you develop
well it really depends because some
people have
they have a very specific style in chest
some people
love playing super close positions some
people love playing
super active positions so i can't
recommend it
because i would have to know your style
or you would have to know your style
but depending on what style of chats you
like to play you
could easy you could have an easier time
figuring out what openings to play
yeah thank you thank you right well i
didn't show this game in 2018 i showed
it about
three months ago still yes queen a6 is
the best one
good job um the idea with queen s a6
is that you have two different
undefended pieces on this diagonal
so i'm gonna come poke them the one
thing that i do absolutely love about
black's position is that everything is
defended with something else so
yes uh in the game white played rook f2
defending the queen i like it and
now knight e5 if you were to take it
this exchange it's better for
black because this bishop is kind of
blinded
also this bishop and this rook are still
inactive my bishop is more activate than
yours if you play something like bishop
f4
i could simply take it after take
now something maybe like rook cafe to go
after this
soon there will be e5 and this is a
classic type of bad bishop versus good
knight
because your bishop is the same color as
your central pawn
so in the game uh knight e5
emma dief didn't want to take it he
played knight f4 now
question should we exchange the queen or
do we have a better move
should we take the chance to take or
no no nobody said good night nice
okay actually that was a good pawn
thanks
i didn't get it for a second well to be
fair we want to exchange the queen
but the problem is that we want you to
take my queen i don't want to take your
queen
i want you to take my queen i want you
to take this
so that's why knight c5 is a better
choice because it kind of pushes you to
take it
take now i take that we don't really
care about this pawn we care about the
peace activity this bishop is poor this
bishop is kind of crying
so white fighter e2
and
this is a very strong end game so after
rookie 2
you are just simply defending and you're
just trying to as white
your position you had a better position
in the middle game now black is
holding a little bit of upper hand
because now i can simply start poking
your pieces out and you can't touch this
knight you can
try to touch this knight but then my
bishop will be opened
so that's why black is doing better now
black way to h6 to try and poke this
light out
now we play a5 no poking this light so
this game just turned into from peace
activity to pokey pokey
and it's another it's kind of fun to for
me
um yeah crying bishops make my
make me happy so i'm the opponent if
your bishop cries i'm happy
um after a5 white played something like
bishop
e3 now a4 it's like kind of daring you
come take me if you can
if you take it i'll take it with d good
luck touching this knight
or good luck activating dick this bishop
so in the game and mdr simply played
rook t1
bringing pressure on this poor guy rook
c6 defending
um bishop d4 bringing more pressure
g5 we we had played this h6 to play g5
remember
and now knight goes to h3
to be fair i think taking was another
ideal to try and kind of
get a little bit of tempo on it
but or maybe um now after g4 knights
could go to f2
try to still hold some pressure or poke
in my
language uh however in the game i'm a dr
of just one knight history
g4 knight came back to f4 um
if the knight went to f2 there would be
some h5s that's why they were talking
about take take
first and then this um
so
now in this position um
we played sorry mamadia played knight f4
now what do you think black should do
lessons about temples are never
are trying to come up with a good word
never
useless well no lesson is useless
lessons with temples are always going to
be in your hearts
that just sounds cheesy lasagna temples
are good
it's almost as good as coffee in a gold
cup there you go
i was a little worried my coffees might
be expired
i remember i i amazon them a while ago
all right so i see some nice ideas with
jerk v8
knight to f3 i'm not the biggest fan of
knight f3 this is my good night that's
your bad bishop i'm giving you this
night
so um i think
it's easier to just go for such
a nice idea such as rook b6 again i
think recreate would be good but
i don't really want to deal with my
weakness pawn
so work b6
and after rook b6 white played knight h5
trying to act take away my bishop we'd
like this bishop right let's keep this
bishop
uh mama dark wins rook d2
with double r rooks simple and sweet
bishop c5 dc5 and check
i wouldn't exactly recommend on taking
because if you take
uh i mean can i take this wait
okay the problem is that you have to go
k5 the sinking king h7
and this stroke is too activated because
if you play like
then you have like 4k8 poking my pawns i
eat your pawn you eat my pawn
and then you eat the other one it's not
a good idea don't give your opponent
activity so don't take that
but do bring your king up i believe king
h7
is also just as good but king f7 is a
little bit more towards the center makes
me slightly happier
take take and rook
goes to d2
um
so now black to move what do you think
we should do
there are different ways to follow up on
here
at least two of these three ways that
are pretty good
any of them that you suggest i will
happily
um go off on
king e7 i like it lightsaber i like it
magnus liked it magnus did it the other
move that i was gonna recommend was a3
knight c4 is just the easiest one you
give check i'll
save my king you take over here now
the better thing bishop e5 kind of
putting your knight in a pickle
and in the game it was kind of funny
because
black dwight took rook takes a4 and
magnus did this one move and black
and white resigned so what do you think
is this one move
and no it's not my takes on b2
no no no no resigning knight e3 there we
go knight e3 is the best one
because now rook b2 is also coming up
and white actually just simply resigned
here because if you played something
like b3
now i can just play rook d8 coming from
the other side
kg1 i can just go rook d2 and this is
just way too painful to continue
as as we can imagine but
um again my point is
that's well magnus in baby magnus is
pretty strong
so uh there's another game that i want
to show you
over here but we're not going to have
enough time to get through all of it so
i'm just going to skip through the
opening i'll show you
the opening for like first 10 moves and
then i'm going to jump
to the middle game of it
simple ponds bye bye
let's get my pieces of simple gambits
magnus is black he probably needs a win
and let's see which which round was this
game this was round 10 so he definitely
needs a win
queen a5 just trying to survive the
opening and i'm pretty sure this was a
lot of preparation beforehand
i'm like no way this was not preparation
anyways so we got to castle castle and
i just wanted to give you a brief
overview of how the game started
now i'm gonna jump ahead to move 30
and show you from here a little bit
there is a critical position
in about five to six six seven moves
um now let's start from here to just so
that you guys can get a small feeling of
the position
black to move what do you think black
should do
to be fair right now white has a huge
advantage
and we're trying to figure out
well what should black do
i'll give you maybe about two minutes so
you can also kind of get a little
feeling for the position
try to have the chance to evaluate the
position um
try to come up with some candidate moves
try to
get slightly panicked about this pawn
so i see the idea of rook d5 but
the problem of rook d5 is that
simply uh remember this bishop is pinned
so bishop e6 works and
oops
rook f8 seems to be the only move to
keep
the pieces but the problem is that even
if you
keep your pieces that is not going to be
good enough
you don't you need more than just
keeping your pieces you need to actually
actively
um use them so how can you keep your
peace activity which
which move helps you keep your peace
activity
oh exquisite i'm glad that i helped
deconfuse you yeah
no unfortunately none of these rook
moves work knight b2 is the best queen
goes to f3 i tried to take that
this is a still super loss for whack
black played queen b1
all white had to do was play simple
simple moves
this is a good enough uh taking on e7 is
another
great move taking on f5 just good enough
you take back white played g4 best move
queen goes all the way back
now bishop takes e7 white is completely
winning this is like plus
seven black played h5
trying to create some room for breathing
and yes magnus is black yeah and
now i think white started to kind of
go a little easy on him and
now here white made a mistake
why fight bishop c7 to be fair this is
not such a humongous mistake because why
it still has a lot of advantage
but this was like kind of the start of
it it might have been easier to just
take over here if you take
i'll simply take that and uh this is a
these two pawns are super dominating
it's just a little bit easier
for white to just handle this
compared to taking on c7
now black played bishop f5 what do you
think white should do
and i believe this is where
it started to go down
so it's kind of funny because it looks
like white got confused
trying to decide how to win there are
like so many different
ways to win so yeah
queen e7 is the best move thank you
but um well in the game
white played queen to e3
and that was a mistake can you tell me
why it's a bad idea
magnus did kind of go pew pew he kind of
does that usually
27 was the best idea you were correct
now what do you think white should do
sorry sorry what do you think black
should do to this white's mistake super
sorry
yeah eat the free stuff it's kind of
funny
because now black is a black is actually
thriving and white isn't a pickle
because
if you go to f2 or g1 boom bishop d4
if you go to f1 again i can just try
something like knight d1 you
have to move this queen and then i have
different type of checks coming up and
that's also going to be checkmate
now it's winning for black um
in the game white played king g3 it's
still
kind of still hoping for equality but
black has a very strong move that
stops that so black to move what should
we do and keep in mind that
our main idea is that we want to bring
bring
all the pieces to work together also i
have so many cat hairs on my face
ugh i think that's the only thing that
i'm not super happy about
um having a cat
way too many hairs the rest is amazing
also if you could just yeah be super
super cute
yeah knight c4 nice
yep knight c4 is great and after
knight c4 is so great because if
you right now it's kind of the best idea
for bla for white to play rook d8
and lose the other pawn as well and then
play something like queen b3
to try to keep some activity and then
drop the other one too
and now it's three pieces and against
two rook
and now this is actually better for
black
then that's the best line after you lost
your d5 r
in the game von belly played quinto f2
and can you tell me how can black
continue
there's like a super killer move
queen d3 good job and after queen d3
king g2
keep in mind king s4 doesn't work
because well first of all
i have that right second i'll uh if you
go to king g2 again i have this bishop
check
you kind of have to take it because if
you don't then i have some background
cool checks
so he took here i take my queen uh sorry
i take with my queen
um king f1
and now what do you think we should do
all right i see great ideas are coming
in i see
that you guys are really thinking about
having this um
checks and checks a lot of bishop d4s
bishop d4 is a little weird i like it
but it's a little weird because
you give it your opponent the chance to
give you checkmate
so bishop d4 is like the next move right
now you got to do something else so you
got to do this check first
and if he went to g1 then yeah you would
have bishop d4
if he went to g2 then he would have
knight e3s
and if as in the game queen went to e2
knight
we give this check and if again he went
king f2 we would have bishop d4
uh in the game with king e1 now
knight f3 check king of one
well actually move what do you think we
should do this is kind of a cool move
too
yeah sir
okay i think you guys got it yes we
gotta eat ponds yasser style
kingy one now you give this cool check
king goes to g2 what is the killer move
last move and black wins actually it's
not checkmate
just yet but it is actually checkmate in
seven
moves but you can lose your queen so i
should that i think that should be
enough
so what do you think should happen right
now
yep g3 you guys got it great g3
is the best move of the position and it
kind of leads to
bye bye queen and after g3 white
actually resigned
so one of the big lessons that i want
you guys to learn from this position
from the last game i wanted you to guys
to look at the concept of putting
pressure and at peace activity
but from this one was that here
white is super winning it's like plus
seven
but here white is actually struggling to
find a draw so be very mindful even if
you have like a super winning position
try to still keep on fighting and keep
the fight going
uh make sure like be aware that your
opponent can still have some tricks
it's one of the beauties of chess you
can be super losing and still have some
tricks up your sleeve
so be very careful of these ideas
and make sure to check the tata steel
tournament that's going to start from
tomorrow i believe tonight was the
opening ceremony
but make sure to check that out as well
and
also join me tomorrow on twitch for
our usual king and pawn warfare and
tactics on 5-7 central time
and with that i will leave you and i
will
probably go try and run a little bit
probably will fail but even if i run 10
minutes
i can say i ran makes it a little less
guilty over chocolate so i'll probably
do that
and i will see you guys tomorrow